[Music]
every morning your neural chip alarm
goes off at 5 a.m metropolitan standard
time
you'd prefer to be woken up by the sun
but nobody in your sector of the city is
allowed to venture to the upper levels
to experience real sunlight
oh well
chip regulated hormones and artificial
sunlight work well enough for the likes
of us
even at this early hour you hear the hum
of metropolis all around you
the artificial sun lamps warming up
their bulbs the garbage bots circling
the city floor to sweep up the trash
the workers trudging to express a later
terminals
you roll out of your cot and switch on
the tiny sun lamp over the tiny
workbench you crammed into the corner of
your room
as you approach the table gb3 whirrs
awake
you greet him fondly as you pat his head
the robot nuzzles up next to you its
metal fur is cold this morning but you
don't really mind
the good boy 3000 is a canine companion
robot the most advanced technology of
its kind well
except for the fact that they're up to
the 7000 series now
and this isn't the real deal
those cost hundreds of thousands of
credits
you found a good as new good boy 3000
neuro coil at the scrap yard a few years
back and figured you could learn how to
build one
years of tinkering and experimenting
later you built your best friend
speaking of the scrapyard you glance at
the nano clock from the corner of your
heads up display
you have about 45 more minutes left to
work on gb3 before you have to head to
the expresso laters to get to work on
time just thinking about your dead
circuit of a boss makes you grumble to
yourself
if you're even a second late you're
fired
you shiver at the thought
losing your job would mean your parents
would be furious and what little credits
you did have would quickly dry up
you motion for gb3 to sit in front of
you on the workbench
you flip on his maintenance switch and
start to examine his auxiliary memory
backup subsystem
you've been getting up early for months
now to spend time on this
it's not a feature that these robots
have but that hasn't stopped you from
taking the time and effort to figure out
the mechanics on your own
everything from the hours spent trolling
the holodecks to study robot manuals to
showing up to your workbench every day
to tinker and experiment with parts
if you can solve it gb3 will be the only
dog in metropolis with this tech
your hard work is paid off your gb3 is
as good as the newest 7000 series they
keep showing on the telebeam
you shake your head
you can't even imagine owning something
that expensive
who even has that many credits
a solar in the upper levels you guess
you've been trying to make a memory
input of gb3 for weeks now
if something were to happen with gb3 you
could initiate a restoration process
that would bring him back to life
the thought of losing him his memory
data well
it's unthinkable
you have a promise you made to yourself
that you take very seriously
some progress just any little thing
every day while working on gb3
but the last week or so has been rough
you check the clock again
you're running low on time for today and
while everything seems to be connected
properly it just hasn't been working
still
your promise
you find an empty power connection on
one of the components
that components already connected to the
main feed so you're not quite sure why
there's another lead going to it but hey
it's something
you wire it up put a dab of solder on
the connection
and start closing the access panels
you'd opened
you even use an upgraded replacement
panel over your custom enclosure to
ensure progress for today
in case the power thing was a dead end
you flip the maintenance switch back off
and grab your satchel as gb3 wears to
life behind you he greets you by rubbing
the whole length of his body along your
leg shoulder to tail
his signature move which you taught him
on your own
you give him a few quick pats on the
head and hurry out the door
you check the data pad and immediately
see the alerts you'd been missing while
tinkering
expresso later is out
again
it's not the end of the world you only
take it one stop anyhow but the
alternative is a hyper psychopath you
always try to avoid
you hate showing up to work already
caked in dirt
you sigh run to your bike and head out
to the edge of metropolis
this is probably the closest you've ever
cut it
it looks like you'll arrive just a
minute or two before the start of your
shift
and that's if nothing else goes wrong
thankfully nothing does and a short
while later you're hopping off your
hyper cycle and sprinting to the gate of
the rusty rodeo your satchel slapping at
the top of your leg
you skid through the door just as the
hourly reminder blares across the
tele-beam from the metropolitan council
you are in sector 22 of the metropolis
industrial reclamation zone
travel is prohibited to solar
thank you
you hate being reminded how stuck you
are in this place but since you just
swiped in on time you've still got a job
and you've got gb3 too
the scrapbot at the gate chirps
dangerous debris detected
that's odd you usually don't get new
scrap until later in your shift
you turn to look at what came into the
yard but for now all you see is the
massive magnet engaged in front of the
gate
when it lifts
you drop your wrench as you see gb3
stuck to the underside his visor dim
a good boy 3000 can't survive a magnetic
field like that they're still working on
that for the 8 000 line and they're not
even out yet
no no no you must have accidentally
enabled guardian mode as you gave him
one last pat on the head out the door
dutifully he followed you and you took
him right to the biggest magnet you've
ever seen in your life
you run over to the scrapbot and shove
it aside overriding the controls for the
scrap magnet gently you lower it back in
front of the gate and disengage the
magnetic field
you hear gb3 collapse to the dirt and
you start to choke up a bit
you hoist the magnet back to its resting
position and sprint over to the gate
gb3 is lifeless as you roll him over to
flip the maintenance switch and open the
access panel
the upgraded panel you use today feels
like it weighs 10 times as much as it
did when you put it on
oh
wow
a small amber led glows inside the
custom memory enclosure
you glance over and see a symbol on the
access panel that you didn't recognize
it feels like lightning tearing through
your brain as you make the connection
that's the symbol for magnetic shielding
you learned about it while studying the
parts you needed back when you first
built gb3
excitedly you run for a volt pack gb3 is
still out and you need to bring in some
outside power to see if this thing's
going to work
you slide back next to him on your knee
pads and make the connection
the led flashes green twice then turns
back to solid amber
you hear a click from inside his main
access panel you jump up and without
even bothering to reattach the panels
you squint your eyes shut and flip the
maintenance switch
it worked gb3 blinks to life writes
himself and displays a message in block
letters across his visor i knew you
could fix me
he wags his whole body then rubs his
shoulder down to his tail against your
leg it's really him
you knew you could fix him too
you whisper as much as you kneel back
down and wrap him in your arms you think
back on everything you learned
everything you did to get to this moment
with your dog
each one of those hours you put in have
played their part
you look lovingly into gb3's visor and
you swell with a bit of well-earned
pride
gb3 might not have all the features that
the newer models come with but he's got
something even better
you
[Music]